Premier lancé, tu nous a trouvé quoi ?
C'est marrant
C'est un amplificateur il me semble
Assez vieux, intéressant
On est sous un pont, qu'on a jamais fait
C'est le fleuve Aude, il y a pas mal d'eau
On est en compagnie de Alex, il y a ScottyFive qui va nous rejoindre
Il y a le fils d'Alex Gaetan qui est là aussi
C'est prometteur ici, assez profond
On va voir ce que ça donne, on fait un lancer en direct
Ah ! J'ai des câbles
Des câbles bizarres
C'est un morceau de voiture ça ?
C'est un carburateur de mobylette
C'est bon signe
Là on a quelque chose de gros
Gros et qui fait pas mal de bulles
Il est un peu venu et a lâché
L'endroit est compliqué
Ce spot je l'aime bien les gars, je crois qu'on aura pas fini aujourd'hui
Tu as besoin d'aide ?
Il y a du rouge
Ca a l'air vieux
Il y a déjà des pédales, ça c'est sûr
Je vais l'attraper
Il y a un rocher avec
Forcément, c'est lourd
Oh oui !
Je vous l'ai dit les gars, je sentais le pistolet aujourd'hui
Incroyable
Regardez
Bien vu Alex, t'imagines on le jète
Magnifique, il est vieux
Laisses les rochers, c'est rigolo
Celui là, je ne pense pas qu'on puisse le restaurer
Autant le laisser avec rochers, c'est plus stylé
Ouais c'est vrai
Regardes son état, il est mort
C'est joli, il est francais je crois, il y a marqué FR
Magnifique
On va faire une photo au soleil
Je le sentais le pistolet ici les gars
Il est fossilisé
Lui on sait qu'il a passé quelques années dans l'eau
Il date peut être de la Seconde Guerre Mondiale
Si on frotte il ne restera rien
Il n'y a pas le chargeur
Super
Il était fossilisé au vélo
Collé au vélo
C'est bizarre ces cailloux collés au vélo aussi
Faut regarder le vélo de plus prêt, il est peut être de la même époque
Peut être
Pistolet Français calibre 7.65 modèle "l'Unique Type R" années 1920 - 1930
Un fossile de vélo
Les archéologues vont trouver des choses comme ça
On va le garder comme ça celui là je pense
Tu ne peux pas restaurer ça
Il faudrait le mettre dans l'eau
Qu'est ce qu'on a de beau ?
C'est lourd
C'est du bois ?
Non, il n'y a pas que du bois
C'est un pot d'échappement ?
A mon avis il y a le reste de la moto
Sympa
On dirait un morceau d'échafaudage
Dommage
Une grosse munition de la guerre
Elle est plus grosse que du Mauser pour le Kar 98
Elle est plus longue
Je ne sais pas l'année
Peut être de la guerre
Belle trouvaille en tout cas
Plus qu'à trouver l'arme
On a coincé un aimant, on a donc envoyé un deuxième pour le décoincer
Souvent quand n fait ça on trouve des choses entre les deux
On fait les meilleurs trouvailles
Ok, une plaque
C'est un vrai ?
C'est quoi ça ?
Il est en métal quand même
Peut être à plomb, pas à billes en tout cas
Peut être un 22LR
RECK font des 22LR
C'est eux qui ont fait le revolver 1 coup que tu avais trouvé
En 22LR c'était la même marque RECK
C'est une marque allemande
C'est gros pour du plomb
C'est de l'acier
C'est bizarre qu'il n'y ait pas les chargeurs
Il est beau, il est rigolo
C'est dommage qu'il n'y a pas la culasse
Ca doit valeur rien du tout
C'est le type de pistolet qui coute le moins cher
Un pistolet de braquage
C'est du plastique
Calibre 7.65, c'est celui là
Donc c'est un vrai
Combien il vaut ?
200 euros
Ah oui, c'est rien
Un pistolet à 200 euros, c'est rien
Une arme encore
C'est bien le même
Faut trouver l'autre bout par contre, et les deux chargeurs
Deuxième arme de la journée les gars !
Rasta, tu les surveilles
Il ne faut pas oublier que, qui dit pêche à l'aimant dis pas mal de galères
On vient de sortir le treuil
Il y a combien ? Deux aimants coincés ?
Oui
On peut coincé un aimant, mais pas deux
C'est vrai qu'on en a déjà coincé 5
Bien joué
Le deuxième est juste au bord Quentin ?
Non il est coincé là bas
Un aimant sauvé
Si comme nous, vous voulez pêcher des amplificateurs radio et des trucs bizarres avec des antennes
N'oubliez pas, pour un bon aimant passez par Maison de la Détection
Ici on a le plus puissant, le Barbarian 1600 kg
Mais vous avez une gamme avec différentes tailles et différents poids
A partir de 800 / 1000kg c'est très bien
C'est nos partenaires, on a un code PECHEURDETRESORS qui offre 5% sur toute la boutique
Ils font des aimants mais aussi des détecteurs de métaux
800 000 kilos
800 000 kg il a dit
Rasta ? Tu valides 800 000 kg ?
Il ne valide pas, regardes
On a treuillé de tous les côté, pas moyen de débloquer l'aimant, on va passer par le pont
On va nous envoyer la corde
Ca fait déjà plus d'une heure qu'on est bloqué et qu'on ne peut pas pêcher
C'est aussi ça la pêche à l'aimant dans les endroits compliqués
Mais ca vaut le coup, on a déjà fait quelques trouvailles
Allé je monte
Vas y montes !
On va l'accrocher à ca
Accrochez Rasta !
Pas de problème, par le collier
Allé vas-y ! Tires
Il va peut être falloir monter pour les aider à tirer
Je ne suis pas sûr qu'ils y arrivent
Ah c'est venu !
Allé ! Tous les aimants sont sauvés
Bravo
On a réussi à décoincer l'aimant avec ScottyFive, on pêche maintenant d'en haut du pont
On va tester quelques lancés même si ce n'est pas notre spécialité d'en haut du pont
Mais c'est insupportable ! Enfin !
Mais enfin ! Ca ne va pas !
Qu'est-ce que j'ai de beau ?
J'ai quelque chose
Allé une arme ! Une arme !
Une pelle ?
Une bêche ?
On dirait une bêche
Oui c'est un outil de jardin. Elle est plein de béton on dirait
Ils ont dû faire du mortier avec
Dédicace à Pêche Aveuglement
La belle chemise regardes !
Bien joué ça
Tu vois ou j'étais tout à l'heure ?
Scotty, j'ai eu un truc directement
C'est trop lourd !
Mince, c'est trop chiant
C'est nul en plus
Attention, il va tomber
Un échafaudage
ScottyFive c'est trompé, il pêche dans le seau des découvertes
Fais attention à la plaque
Je la soulève mon cousin !
Vas y !
J'ose même plus lancer là bas, si il y en a d'autres
Oh ! Ca fait des étincelles
Ah ouais
On a découvert le feu
Regardes les tâches
Oh les gars ! Regardez les tâches
C'est quand j'ai tiré
Et oui mon cousin, c'est un Vespa
Je ne sais pas ce que c'est mais c'est surement gros
Salut
C'est un silure en fer ?
Ouais un gros silure
Vous voulez un coup de main ?
Oui, ça doit faire 60 kg
Ils ont dit : on arrive
Il y a du béton ? C'est une enclume ?
C'est le le marteau de Thor
C'est lourd
Faites attention au dos
Ne vous faites pas mal au dos les gars
Dommage
Désolé, Thor est arrivé
Bien joué
Merci en tout cas
C'est quoi qui a lâché ? L'aimant
Ouais on peut le repêcher
Mais je ne sais pas si ça vaut le coup
Il doit y avoir une moto aussi
Les mecs ils sont venus jeter un échafaudage complet en fait
Vous pêchez du poisson ici ?
Ouais le silure, en théorie
Là on va aller plus bas
On ne va pas trop tarder sinon je pense
On va aller plus bas, pas de problème
Vous ne vous accrochez pas trop ?
Non ça va, on pêche en Flotte Tube surtout
Il fait combien de puissance l'aimant du coup ?
Celui là 1600kg, dans tous les cas si l'objet fait 100kg c'est un peu le maximum qu'on trouve
Les carcasses de voiture le font bien
Quand il y a des motos on utilise le treuil
Selon ou il est tu dois être bloqué
Ah oui les aimants quand ils se coincent entre les rochers c'est compliqué
C'est quoi votre chaîne ?
Pêcheur de Trésors
Vous apparaitrez en vidéo si ca ne vous dérange pas, pour la tentative avec le marteau de Thor
Cherches pas t'as tort !
Ben bonne pêche ! Merci en tout cas
On va laisser tomber le marteau de Thor, il est trop lourd. Il sera dans la prochaine vidéo
On va se casser le dos sinon
Ca vient
Probablement encore un morceau d'échafaudage
On a un bout nous aussi !
Oui, c'est ça
On a la passerelle de l'échafaudage
Ils l'ont jeté en entier
On dirait ouais
C'est bon pour le ferrailleur
C'était ça qui devait nous bloquer, avec les rochers au milieu
C'est quoi ? Pas un mouton
Un sanglier ?
Regardes, on a trouvé une mâchoire dans l'échafaudage
Il y a les dents et tout avec
Mais pas d'homme
Malheureusement
Il y a des dents vers l'avant
C'est un indice cette dent vers l'avant
Je ne sais pas, si vous savez dites le en commentaire
Les chasseurs !
Rasta, on a besoin de toi pour identifier
Qu'est-ce que c'est ça ?
Il s'en fou
Encore une passerelle d'échafaudage
Amenez la moi
Tirez
J'ai un truc bien, je le sent !
C'est une cisaille !
Ne la casse pas celle là
C'est pour le bois
C'est sympa
Elle est abimée
C'est une arme ?
C'est un pistolet !
Je ne suis pas sûr
T'es sûr ?
Non, c'est trop fin, alors tu es déçu ?
C'est une hache !
On dirait une vieille hache oui
C'est une trouvaille stylé quand même alors
Le manche est bien en bois ?
Ouais c'est du bois
Ouah ! Elle est vieille
C'est très stylé, elle est belle
T'es pas venu pour rien aujourd'hui
Elle est fossilisé aussi
On dirait un peu un pistolet
J'y ai trop cru
Ca reste une arme
Elle est incroyable
Je pense que l'on en a rarement trouvé des aussi vieille
Elle est dans un sale état
Elle a pris cher
Il vaut mieux peut être la garder comme ça, faut voir
Elle sera trop fine
C'est quoi ?
Une boite de vitesse
Envoies ton aimant dessus, tu lui voles
Dommage
Alors Rasta, tu es content il y a une boite de vitesse ?
T'es content mon petit Rasta ?
Il adore les boites de vitesse
Lâches la corde
Bien joué
C'est lourd quand même
Elle est remplie
Ah non ! C'est bite d'amarrage, il y a la chaîne
C'est ça tu crois ?
Oui, oui
Regardes ce qu'il y a dedans
Il n'y a que de l'or
Que de l'or, rien pour toi
Il a prit un coup cet aimant
Il n'a pas de coque, regardes
Il fonctionne bien du coup
Il est long
Ca ne va pas renter ça
On a la disqueuse mais bon
Descend un peu
Qu'est-ce qu'il a pêché encore ?
Juste là ?
Qu'est-ce que c'est que ça ?
C'est un morceau de poteau électrique je crois
Ouais c'est pareil
Viens
C'est pas un aimant ?
Il y a des trucs collés dessus
C'est une enceinte avec un aimant
Enfin, ce qu'il en reste
Elles sont chiantes les mouches
Ouais elles sont collantes
Je n'en ai pas vu une seule
Tu mens, je t'ai vu tout à l'heure tu en avais une sur la bouche
Ben je ne l'ai pas vu
Si
Non
Tu l'as enlevé après, je t'ai vu
Je n'ai pas fait exprès
Si
Non
Ben non
Crois moi
Je l'ai mangé
Je l'ai filmée je pense
Je l'ai mangée ?
Non
Menteur
Tu en as une sur ta casquette
Elle a le droit
Ouais, ouais
Je m'en fou, tu vas avoir des coups de soleil ce soir
Je t'ai filmé en train d'avaler une mouche
Ce soir tu auras des coups de soleil
Je ne parle pas aux mangeurs de mouches
Au moins, elles ne me gênent pas si les manges
Ah ça c'est une première
C'est un téléphérique !
Tu est sûr que c'est un clic-clac ?
Ouais ! On vous décroche vos aimants
C'est pas une table
C'est un clic-clac
J'ai cru à une table
Alors, bilan de la pêche
Deux armes, c'est très rare et ça
Qu'est ce que c'est !
On trouve n'importe quoi dans l'eau
Deux joli gun ça fait plaisir, ça faisait longtemps
De très belles trouvailles ici encore
Bravo !
Belle pêche
Une mobylette
Bien joué
Un vieux cadre de mobylette
Il est c*n ce gosse
Il me l'a mi dans la tête !
Il m'a mi des algues sur la tête
C'est bon Alex
C'était un cadre
Le mien c'est quoi ?
Un disque
Il n'y aurait pas quelque chose là dedans ?
On va regarder
Non, il n'y a rien
On reviendra pour une partie 2 et d'ici là, on vous souhaites de bonnes fêtes de fin d'année